[Music]
first half-court shot or thereabouts in
five short form history and the half
right through
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Middleton 3 the past moves quicker than
the patient says he wants to retire
Hornet tip 6 is a gonna get in the hole
start confessing that kind of love we
want to keep him but you never know
scoring the first two points in fire
served on he had six of the 11 points in
that run Bledsoe
all the other goodies at Farpoint great
views of Milwaukee from the panoramic
view of the basket by Eric Wetzel
Nana spines blood so off the tip so fans
have a shot - you know just a little
little slip acted by Yanis once he
sucked within the basket he put it on
the rim
Toma picks up his first wife Terry
Bledsoe the middle of your screen right
here just a nice job reading that cross
grain pass hush my mouth he's doing it
but that dirt that that that's back down
post up that he is so good at what we
make unbelievable anybody needs a good
cry that's the one Bledsoe buries the
three
[Applause]
Wildcat the Wildcat bluegrass the
bluegrass is to a twenty one from three
o'clock and gives off the flipside shop
counting
I think that's gonna be curry second
it's got two on the bench for Golden
State
with a pump fake right there let's--oh
gets his body on the shot clock
let's show steps back three baby plan
show it took forever to drop through him
well it took forever for the Bucks to
get a look at the basket not even a
clean look that's a 16 gallon re on the
contestant gets it to an eric bledsoe
but
[Applause]
good hands
Middleton he has Bledsoe to his right
time up in the passing lane Chris uses
the strong side hand to tap it away they
get a two-on-one situation Milwaukee
with 43 points in the quarter
they're season-high for a third
[Applause]
one of the most dangerous teams from
three and Bledsoe has been a rolling
Hawley call
tie it at 75 the Bucks take the way wet
so Lopez streets up for the back screen
that frees Bledsoe for the grave
[Music]
what Joe gets down
and he's talking to Booker he knocks it
out of bounds if you don't have a good
game like they didn't against Phoenix
[Applause]
that's how you do that
three two
[Music]
yes
let's so sing hey now I got a big spell
on me let me show you something get all
the way to the rack just before the
buzzer these are not easy shots as a
third one in a role that he shot me
off-balance from freaking and then blend
so came right back and hit a three of
his own man I mean he would fly and dump
and their worth in two years he was a
joke shooter found it and me like that
bull fest came in and now he's a trap
shoot at Milwaukee a Monday he did play
Wednesday against the next maybe he'll
get some time against Yanis that's one
possibility Bledsoe goes in uncontested
through the pink Pistons lashed to the
Bucks by 23 Bledsoe beautifully done he
made a little move that throws Drummond
and he saw the slot and took it and we
get filled by puts we wasn't even
stirred and grounded on the floor based
on what he's done in this game
another great defensive play Griffin
lost his dribble and trying to give it
up Bledsoe picked it fans Yanis finger
roll for straight-4 out of the combo and
one time you look at the three-pointers
made both teams had four and you thought
all my goodness retired from three
there you go season go through the net
many different former Knicks would
especially king when it comes to not
going to hate he's been through it all
Bledsoe puts it in plus the foul and
Vaughn late to the shot just look at him
right here nice fake pass gets a hand
one but we talked about Bernard King and
some of the legends that have been able
to come back I mean they paved the way
for us in a major way to game over five
minutes remaining fourth quarter Lopez
big size advantage on Courtney lady
Bledsoe step back he shook money and
hits the green 287 first team to 100
wins right we'll see
Wilson was an unknown commodity to Blake
Griffin the first time these team spent
a couple weeks ago Mitchell takes it all
the way to the restricted area to score
his onboard Griffin has the ball in his
hand off a lot and catching his hand to
make the adjustment on the offensive end
flexo eight points quadruple that at
least tonight Wetzel passed the test
[Applause]
just execution they don't get him going
they got Lowry and Bella tunas out there
trouble
a simple stroll down her poor way to the
ground
two of the shotgun
he got in the way and they're going to
look at it to see if he got it away to
hear that he did break
it's not too late to make one more ring
right for the bonus malcolm thrown in
the head
cleaver say i'm gonna go for led so cuz
i said so but he was struggling a bit
knocking down the long ball so what does
he do to the chef's that the Bucks want
their opponents to make on a consistent
basis
Wow let's roll beer please completed
that's with the bad wrist 610 250 pounds
[Applause]
good job Yanis knocks it away
once again Bledsoe Jackson Yanis who
started it paid off by blood so that's a
great teammate and a great point guard
energy office dunks but just a great job
yawns without fouling and Bledsoe
beautiful no-look behind the back drop
pass down let's doesn't rest basketball
is such a pretty game that's an all-time
grave right there Bledsoe Marcus said so
it's in consideration the collaboost the
[ __ ] ever to win
Lando let's go
Wow doctor where my opinion should be up
foremost in who one of the leading
candidates why because he can do so many
things on his team
how about blessed oh he's found to hope
groans your son away
roll is with this Toronto ballclub
breathe its fans of steel by blood so
he'll come the other way about us
trailers watching his diet that we just
buy it in buying in like like the book
players of barter
[Applause]
pillbot walking great to have led so bad
this point of attack activity in terms
of active hands dinu's soul
ahead of the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Bledsoe yes you're gonna mention it
Madison - both under 10 precipitated by
the hustle of Earth Sun hill your sofa
on the weak side bug dips and looking to
throw that thing down but down has had
other plants mean intention so it picks
it up
[Applause]
flexo crossover what a great rifle pass
- choice now fifty one forty third is
that pass BAM flush haven't brought into
the system and being the guys that give
you that level of support
bludsoe the paper that was also his
first attempt speech
let's--oh cheaters in the lane and
finishes over Rondo may have taken a
shot to the face talked about the size
of the arms of Eric Bledsoe earth
Bledsoe is the only buff to score in the
last five minutes and thirty seconds not
a teen Haines that step cute little
package or stop by competently slips
behind Lashon Rhonda five on four for
the Bucks is ingre he's not back yet
Bledsoe will take you back Eric Bledsoe
my contract day to the Miss by Weiss
[Applause]
Bledsoe bribe score and one if it gets
old left the right crossover led so
quick as a hiccup and one boy that's
great recognition what you saw a post up
guy that was Williams it was cleared out
by middle
[Music]
[Applause]
good job of inverting their offenses
burn brown with the not beams eric
bledsoe what the two day
offensive tendencies she's not just
taken away the three-point shot and
challenging the layup makeup tonight I'm
here being able to go through Austin
Rivers arms dead hard back to the day
the glutes out to get that side out here
bring on missus playing D on the beard
get that shot out of here players only
on TNT overtime victory back in
Goldmember against the Bucks they were
plus 6 at the line and everything else
was fairly even he's three pointer
beautifully done by Bledsoe single-a in
but it was the right idea
yeah it was good he gets it back tell
you what that guy makes a little mistake
you'll get it back for you when he did
Jim just so smart you do shamon want to
come up with commits the early foul
Temari Carol Wetzel all the way down to
knock that out of bounds great hustle by
flex show in Jerusalem and bounded to
Lopez now Bledsoe sealed by fools and he
said you know what I'm thinking on a
shot at then in the regular shoes but
and it's not like you know you're going
out there cognizant of that bag you just
plain
you just you just play we just playing
at a high level Eric Bledsoe he said
that the who've already a double-double
and a klutz get everything they want to
players typically
[Applause]
on a three-point rattle a movement to
standardize that time justice 958 French
oh great play
yeah and let so just kind of flooding
the passing lane active hands and they
were down as if they've been knocked out
Blake is not moving as well this half
double off you see they're at second
Pachulia in this pick-and-roll they
didn't know what to do
it's nice slam dunk down the paper and
four years $70,000,000 extension a
couple months ago in season led so that
cat Jim of finish they walk four five
six points four assists ultra four from
free
[Applause]
this is so graceful inside scoring in
the paint
hey what got the staff thought he was
found I mean he officials will scream
six-second differential deep pocket shot
clock at blood so fires of three cuts
right back
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content